on essayé d'imaginer un scénario un peu
fou pour 2022 moi c'est à dire ce serait
pas mon rêve le plus fou mais mon
cauchemar jeu plus fous on peut dire ce
serait d'imaginer que justement dans la
lignée de 700 événements rousseau qui a
été écarté pour l'instant christiane
taubira qui est en train d'être poussés
par une primaire populaire qu'on nous
dise de 200000 personnes qui veulent
élire en dehors des partis leur candidat
le plus à même de représenter toute la
gauche christiane taubira donc
deviennent cette candidate quasi unique
de la gauche rassemble sous son nom et
soit capable de passer au second tour
imaginons voilà que la gauche se
réveillent que les français se mettent à
avoir peur de la fin du monde donc de
l'écologie n'est pas uniquement de la
fin du mois mais aussi la fin du mois en
regardant combien maquereau en mener une
politique libérale et comment ils en
train de détruire la france sur ce plan
là cette gauche se réveillent
plein de volonté de justice sociale
pleine de volonté d'un terreau sectional
it et voyant christiane taubira une
grande poétesse et une grande politique
capable et à même de réduire toutes les
inégalités et donc se retrouver au
second tour face à emmanuel macron
qu'elle bat à plates coutures et voilà
et on se retrouve avec christiane
taubira comme président de la république
en avril prochain voilà mon scénario 6
[Musique]